[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you all thank you good afternoon
you know
[Applause]
well this is why we're here today
because of this energy this commitment
this passion this love of our country
and our willingness to fight for it good
afternoon everyone good afternoon
the people in this room work so hard in
this election
Staffing the polls answering people's
calls answering voter protection calls
driving people to the vote and among the
captains of the team my husband the
second gentleman Doug Empire
are phenomenal first lady Dr Jill Biden
all right
[Applause]
and our one and only President Joe Biden
[Applause]
[Music]
you did it Joe
[Applause]
could help myself
so as We Gather here
votes are still being counted
but it is clear
your work sent a message to the entire
world
our democracy is intact
[Applause]
like
and here's the thing some Democrats won
and some Republicans won that is what
happens when more than 100 million
Americans participate and vote in free
and fair and open elections
that's what happens
and that included young people seniors
parents with children in tow working
people
who all made their voices heard
and the people in this room and around
our country made that possible by
standing up for basic American values
freedom
Liberty and the rule of law
and I believe when you know what you
stand for you know what to fight for
this year
like so many of you I traveled across
our country we convened students and
Faith leaders organizing and advocating
to protect the sacred right to vote we
convened candidates and elected
officials defending the right to retire
with dignity
by defending Social Security and
Medicare
and of course everywhere I went we
brought together people fighting for
Reproductive freedom
people everywhere from every background
because here's the thing one does not
have to abandon their faith or deeply
held beliefs to agree the government
should not be telling a woman what to do
with her body
foreign
voters across our country knew what they
stood for so they knew what to fight for
they protected and they protected and
they protected Reproductive Rights in
Vermont in Michigan in California and in
Kentucky
[Applause]
so to everyone who made that possible
thank you
thank you for working the long hours
and the late nights for protecting
voting rights on behalf of every
American in every community in every
political party
and to the millions of Americans who
waited in line who mailed in your ballot
who rejected big lies and extremism and
participated in our democracy thank you
[Applause]
you knew what you stood for four so you
knew what to fight for you fought for
rights and freedoms that will make our
country more fair more safe and stronger
and you were not fighting alone
from day one our president
has fought on behalf of all Americans
and our democracy
Joe Biden understands the Dual nature of
democracy its fragility and its strength
he's been talking about it since day one
the strengths of democracy
that lie in principles
about treating people equally and
electing people fairly
to lift up instead of to beat folks down
and this President understands
democracy is only as strong
as our willingness to fight for it
and no one fights harder for our
democracy than the people in this room
and this president
he knows what we saw again this week
when we fight
we win
my fellow Americans
president of the United States Joe Biden
foreign
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
come on and Doug by the way Doug
crisscross the country I think he did he
spent more time making sure that the
folks who actually count the votes in
these states do it honestly and thank
you Pat
foreign
folks on behalf of Jill and myself we're
here for a simple reason to say thank
you from the bottom of my heart not a
joke we mean this this is not a
political piece this is to say thank you
thank you thank you most of all thank
you for believing in your country thank
you no I really mean it thank you for
fighting like the devil to make sure
that we had a free and a fair election
and you know all those election deniers
so far best of my knowledge none of them
has not said they when they lost they
said we lost
that's a big deal no I I I really mean
it you know Tuesday was a good day for
America a good day for democracy it was
a strong night for Democrats
for months and months all of you heard
from the press and the pundits was it
Democrats are facing the disaster
remember that
and all those polls all those polls God
loved them you know
historic losses were on the way a giant
red wave
folks that didn't happen you know we
were talking backstage here before we
came out each of us crisscrossing the
country all four of us and we're saying
we'd come back and say I don't know what
they're talking about no no no I'm
serious the overwhelming response we
were getting and the fact that even
those folks who uh may not like me or
may not like somebody but they they
agree with our agenda they thought we
were what we were doing you know by the
way
all the Democrats ran on the same agenda
without being told look while votes are
being counted we don't know the outcome
of all the races here's what we do know
we lost fewer seats than House of
Representatives any Democratic
President's first elected midterm at
least 40 years
we had the best midterms for governor
since 1986.
[Applause]
and experts said we couldn't beat the
odds but we did beat the odds
and we did it for one reason this is not
hyperbole because of you and all of you
up and about by the it's hard to see up
in the balcony but God love you
I really mean it because of you you
believed in the system you believed in
the institutions you felt like help for
it and that's the most important thing
that happened in my view in this
election it was the first national
election since January 6th and there
were a lot of concerns about whether
democracy would meet the test it did it
did it did
and I want to complement all those
mainstream Republicans I mean if they
get in they fall like we usually fight
and they we got a result and we accepted
it everybody accepted so for many of you
you organized you got the vote out you
volunteered at the polls think of all we
heard before this election about all the
people being intimidated all the people
being threatened at the polls all the
people who worked the polls despite the
threats and abuses too many poll workers
on the election day and the election
I'll show you I said election officials
experience to have experiences late you
did your job it fulfilled your duty you
showed up you did what you're supposed
to do and so did the American people
look the American people overwhelming
some overwhelmingly support our agenda
law and prescription drug costs making
health care more affordable
rebuilding America revitalizing American
manufacturing taking on climate crisis
finally and finally making big
corporations pay their fair share
preserving democracy and protecting
fundamental rights this is this is a
this is the progress that and the
programs that we ran on this is the vote
that showed it says some real enthusiasm
for what we were what we're fighting for
and guess what it matters you know when
we came to office we inherited a nation
in a pandemic raging and an economy that
was reeling but we went to work all of
you and by the way I know a lot of you
just didn't show up on Election Day
you've been working the last 25 20 or so
months worth but you went to work
building an economy from the bottom up
in the middle out and so you know the
Maggie Republican trickle down Economic
Policy we decided it didn't work for
Americans
our economic policies created 10 million
new jobs
unemployment unemployment went from 6.4
percent down to 3.7 percent one of the
lowest in 50 years
American manufacturing is surging with
700 new manufacturing jobs created and
many more to come and look
as I said all during the campaign where
in the hell is it written in America
can't lead the world in manufacturing we
are and we will and we're going to
continue to folks look
just today we learned inflation came
down last month
mainstream economists are saying this is
a really positive sign of the resilience
of the economic recovery it's going to
take time to get inflation back to
normal levels we could see setbacks
along the way I realize that but we are
laser focused on it that's why it's so
critical for us to pass important
legislation this year to lower those
costs for families and I know it's going
to take time to implement our entire
economic agenda which we already passed
and for folks to field it in their
day-to-day lives but I think folks are
going to see it in the next few months
that's what's going to that and I think
that's what they voted for watch what
happens when people see New Roads
Bridges being built in their towns they
start to see the Investments being made
in electric rail all across America
where they they're gonna it's gonna take
significant number of vehicles off the
road reducing pollution watch what
happens when there's affordable
high-speed internet in every home in
America
watch what happens when they realize we
meant what we said in the lead pipes
start being pulled out of schools day
care centers homes all across America
Watch What Happens in January when
seniors with diabetes on Medicare only
have to pay 35 bucks a month instead of
400 bucks a month for their insulin
Watch What Happens in big Corporation in
America start to pay their fair share
and by the way a 15 tax isn't that
terrible
you all pay more than that
look but in 2020 the 55 largest
corporate of the 55 55 of the largest
corporation in America paid zero on 40
million dollars in profits those days
are over
and watch what happens when new factors
are being built in communities with
America workers making the most advanced
computer chips in the world and by the
way that's going to create thousands of
good paying jobs and I mean jobs between
120 135
000 a year and you don't need a college
degree to do them look
you all made this possible and we're
just getting started we're just getting
started
we saw extraordinary results in these
midterms elections that no one thought
possible more Independents voted for
Democrats and Republicans in this
election young people
you voted historic numbers again just as
you did two years ago young people voted
to continue addressing the climate
crisis gun violence personal rights and
freedom student debt relief all those
things which is stepped up to do
[Applause]
and as I said women in America made
their voices heard man
I said last year that one of the most
extraordinary things about the Dobbs
decision is what was about to challenge
American women when the Justice said
let's see they have it in their power
basically saying let's see what they're
going to do well guess what
you all showed up and beat the hell out
of them
look
I said it then
those who support ripping away the
rights to choose don't have a clue about
the power of women in America but now I
think they do
and we're J and by the way no one worked
harder to get that message Across
America than this lady right here
[Applause]
look I also thank the American people
sent a message that they want us to work
together
I've always done that I know I got
criticized for it when I ran I said I
was running for three reasons one to
restore the soul of America too to build
this economy from the middle out and the
bottom up and thirdly to unite the
country regardless of what the final
tally showed I'm prepared to work with
Republicans but the American people have
made it clear they expect Republicans to
work with me as well
and folks
I'll always be open any good ideas
whether it's democrat or republican to
move the country forward but I've also
made it really clear that if Republicans
try to repeal the power we just gave
Medicare to reduce prescription drug
costs I will veto it doesn't let it
happen
the Republicans try to walk away from
their story commitment we just made to
deal with the climate crisis I will not
let that happen
if Republicans try to cut Social
Security Medicare I will not let that
happen
and if they try to cut taxes for the
super wealthy again the biggest
corporations like they did in the last
Administration I will not let that
happen either
look
and as we look at tax cuts we should be
looking at tax cuts for working people
and middle class people
and I'm going to keep the commitment we
both made that no one making less than
400 Grand a year will ever see a pending
their taxes go up as long as we are in
power
and folks
and I love the Republicans talking about
big spending Democrats we're going to
keep working to keep the federal deficit
low we cut the deficit in two years by
one trillion 700 billion dollars more
than ever in all of American History oh
I don't want to hear if Republicans
calling Democrats Big Spenders they're
we're the ones Bringing Down the
deficits they're the ones that blew it
up over four years
and one more thing
if Republicans pass and I don't think
they can do it now banned the national
band do Bland abortion I will veto it
it's simple
we need to codify Roe v Wade as the law
of the land
look
[Applause]
let me close with this
you've all heard me say it before and
I'll say it again
I honest to God have never been more
optimistic about America's future in the
day and I'm optimistic for a number of
reasons we're better situated than any
nation in the world
any nation in the world to lead the
world we're better positioned any nation
in the world in terms of our economic
growth and possibilities and I'm
optimistic because of the young people
of this nation you've heard me say it
time and again and I meant it your
generation represents the best educated
the most talented the least Prejudice
generation in the history of the United
States America for
I'm not
and by what I wasn't trying to be nice I
would just stating the facts
just stating the facts in 220 in 2020
many of you voted for your first time
and you volunteered in the first
election
well look at what you did when you
exercised your power to vote you elected
Kamal Harris the first woman vice
president of American history
and
you helped me keep my commitment that I
would appoint the first black woman of
the Supreme Court Justice Jackson
and guess what
she's probably the smartest person on
the Supreme Court
and because of your vote this year we're
going to keep building the foundation we
laid for the third in the first two
years
you prove once again on Tuesday that our
democracy and our democracy our
democracy the power in the hands of the
people we know for real we the people it
really is truly in our hands
we set the course for the nation's
future
we just have to remember who in God's
name we are and I'm I hope nothing else
happens remember this
there's not a damn thing I really mean
it from the bottom of my heart not a
damn thing we can't do if we do it
together
we are the United States of America
and you made it better
thank you thank you thank you God bless
you all and may God protect our troops
go get them we've got a lot of work to
do thank you thank you
thank you thank you they won't let me
come down
[Applause]
thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]